ah here we go again acha buying the
house one of the irregular opponents he
plays a Slav trying something different
here I came this one I really have no
idea I remembered someone that he plays
a slob but I couldn't remember the line
okay I like this this kind of variation
here hmm shouldn't be too really there
is no this is really just possible he
decided very quickly on the move I mean
probably it is possible but hmm i get i
get some pods down chicks chicks lurking
then let's done nothing that's not let's
not try to review this just play normal
stuff
you have a bit surprised because this is
taking lots of time
Wow the thing is what makes me very
skeptically is that black is flex
development issues very bad c6 is weak
he has not cancelled so I think it would
be very surprising if this would be a
good way of playing cannot really
believe it okay six is an additional way
to put pressure okay so he went back
let's see mmm the question is before or
not and something better
let's go here for okay dokay 8 castle
sounds just about hauling and I could
have done something better they're
really wonder it looked bad enough to
warrant some direct win but I couldn't I
didn't see any at least this way I did
before super behind on the clock okay I
can take and takes his six which is
probably not bad let's do it
194 it's an interesting question i have
a take Queen takes I'm actually in some
oil somewhat awkward pin let's do this
I'm really not sure you can easily lose
on time in the process of being not sure
okay sixth is not working because Luke
hangs
not sure night be a door something also
looks pretty bad
not sure what my rook is supposed to do
not quite clear what the best squares
yeah the knight on d4 like c6 Quincy
five p5 p6 and wins automatically yeah
this is this this kind of thing is the
only way to disturb this
very lucky that he has this kind of
resource at all h4 was not working and
okay jack so the counter players coming
with with night moves I guess if I go
see 6 equals Queen c3 this kind of thing
oopsie one does not help I guess that's
right preparing preparing c6
yeah look do you wanna have to there's
no choice
94 I will take and then c7 yeah I really
hope that wins I don't see how it saves
that but Quint it to something like
something crazy for rookie one okay to
take this and wonder if 27 is actually a
move and then sister then the zip on it
seems strong actually
after c7 Queen 86 might I have the
Chinese the check as well I can also
take it but why not this let's March the
pawns okay oneness what he wants to do
but ok I can I have checks on f5 check
one check on f5 so if I what is the deal
and promote now I'm not made checking
object and look meter to check check
check check check check make this work
quite quite a number of Queens and yeah
a funny game hmm yeah I really don't
believe in this opening one bit and d5 I
mean there are there are pretty this is
also interesting I was thinking about
this move but i wasn't sure i will win
this but the whole situation is kind of
murky I saw this position and I wasn't
sure what's going on here I had my
doubts that this is any good for black I
mean I've got three pawns bishop fibers
and
mix okay the engine gives away the
klatch after this it wants to already
give material bag but I think this is
also just good because blacks
development is just just really bad and
this is this i don't believe in it just
takes far too long and now he for was
very strong even stronger than what I
did now why twins why I'm just winning
here this is I mean something like this
is going to be awful yeah I only saw
that I get to get to default Wow rucca
a7 is probably stronger than route 86
but it's it's pretty good anyway and
night b5 is even stronger now okays
takes you should have six coin f6 queen
of sex in white wins yeah that's even
stronger and thought that is this must
be good and it seems seems to be okay at
least good for a big advantage yeah that
that's a really good way to defend I
probably shouldn't take on b5 with the
Queen the engine gives this winning yeah
now now I can I'm defending against this
check because of the check and I'm
taking next yeah this is pretty
comfortably winning and this isn't clear
i have it really isn't can aha Queen
have two black wins wow that would have
been a cold shower my week back rank I
had this nagging feeling I didn't see it
didn't see that during the game but
yeah look
awkward yeah at night efore is a draw
according to the comp and I thought I
can take and do this and this is the
draw and I just assistant point amazing
at the Epona's probably probably too
strong I start this I mean this is this
is quick it really is quick so only this
is in fact losing check check and check
and check probably there was some kind
of a quicker wind but it witness a win
thanks for watching